my very dear old friend Justin Long a
boyfriend a dear friend and he and Kate
have found each other in this world and
become this incredibly joyous
bonded real deal
you know holding hands like the ultimate
couple you root for oh thank you
Drew Barrymore gushing over her ex
Justin long and his new fiance Kate
Bosworth it's gonna be real talk and the
ladies did get real when Kate stopped by
Drew's talk show the two clearly proving
you can be friendly with your ex's new
partner he loves you so much
he just loves you so so deeply I asked
him if we could also be open about your
relationship and talk about how we
celebrate our exes yeah and because of
your upbringing because of who you are
we were able to celebrate your
relationship talk about we as women
actually have an opportunity in fact it
was Kate who encouraged Justin who dated
Drew on and off from 2007 to 2010 to
appear on her talk show in September and
I said oh you have to do it I was like
yes yes you have to do it yeah I was so
excited I was so excited because I knew
there's so much love between the two of
you we're just reuniting on National
Television like you do yeah and that
reunion quickly turned emotional I love
that we've maintained our love because
it I I don't think it'll ever and I know
from mine it'll never go anywhere I'll
love you always you know and so I I I'm
glad that we're able to still have that
I mean
[Applause]
I I will always love you so much it's
about rewriting The Narrative that we
create for ourselves and it's not about
your past and it's not about your future
it's about kind of figuring your stuff
out in the here and now in April Kate
and Justin confirmed their engagement
weeks after the actress flashed a
sparkler on that finger at the Vanity
Fair Oscars party
I want to scream it from the rooftops
but I also want to be um protected
sacred but we are happy you are happy
I'm so happy and Drew couldn't be
happier for the couple I'm so thrilled
she does all those that she is and and
she adores you and she is the most
supportive most wonderful it's funny you
want to know we gotta you would love
hanging out we'll all go out yes you can
say Drew and Kate hit things off pretty
well we have a choice of how we can
navigate our partners that we're
currently with with confidence and
blessing yeah and uh uh a sharing
goodness that makes all women look good
and rise and it just was the high road
and I'm like Justin move over it's all
about Kate now
[Music]
thank you